you or someone you know may have been
diagnosed with a mental health problem
this video will show you some ways that
could make the problem a lot better
while there are currently no known cures
for most mental illness the good news is
that recovery is possible
most people diagnosed with a mental
illness can experience relief from their
symptoms by actively participating in an
individual treatment plan common
treatment options include psychotherapy
also known as talk therapy or counseling
and medication medications for mental
illnesses are thought to work on your
brain cells called neurons
in doing so they increase brain activity
in certain areas or decrease activity in
others this can help reduce your
symptoms
for example some medications work to
make more naturally occurring chemical
messengers available these chemicals
pass signals between your brain cells it
is important for brain cells to have
enough of these chemicals in the space
between them to pass the signals
if you have depression you may not have
enough of certain chemical messengers in
this space
in general the use of antidepressant
medications results in the build-up of
certain chemical messengers in this
space this buildup improves signal
transfer and your mood may improve as a
result
other medications work differently or in
ways not yet known in addition to
depression other common mental illnesses
that can be treated with medications
include schizophrenia bipolar disorder
also known as manic-depressive disorder
and many others if you have
schizophrenia your healthcare
professional or doctor may prescribe
antipsychotic medications a mood
stabilizer is usually the first choice
as medication taken on a regular basis
if you have bipolar disorder other
medications prescribed for bipolar
disorder include antipsychotics
antidepressants or drugs known as
atypical antipsychotics mental illnesses
are common you may have a mental illness
not discussed in this video or you may
have been prescribed other types of
medication talk to your healthcare
professional or doctor if you have
questions about your medication or have
any side effects it is important to take
your medications as directed by your
healthcare professional or doctor do not
stop taking them unless your healthcare
professional or doctor tells you to if
you stop taking your medications your
symptoms may reappear